world like I'm assuming that the big
monolithic healthcare system is not
going to just stand by why you print
tens of millions of dollars in revenue
and say you know we don't care about
that what have you seen either in
response from legacy players or do you
see maybe not direct responses but like
behavior changes or anything that yeah I
mean you know the two largest players in
lab testing or two publicly traded
companies quest diagnostics and lock
where they are you know they're huge
companies and they focus on a very
different part of the service delivery
model R&D brick-and-mortar owning the
lab value chain we do not own the lab
value chain we partner across the
country right so they really are in a
different business my argument would be
they're not in the business that serves
the patient that does not mean that they
don't care about the patient they're
just in all these different types of
businesses for where their competency is
we have great relationships with both of
them to be honest I'm not sure we're yet
big enough to cause them any pain I have
seen though they've both revamped or
relaunched their direct-to-consumer or
consumer initiated businesses in the
last 18 months to two years and most
recently
LabCorp launched pixel kind of took
shuddered it a bit and then as
relaunched it as part of their code at
19 response and then quest has a quest
direct business to go in and have blood
draws that they've they've amped up a
lot of their social advertising social
media advertising on I think what is
undervalued by most healthcare
organizations this is not not specific
to LabCorp inquest is the value of
community customer experience and brand
and that is something that is difficult
to build we have an NPS score across the
business of a 70 plus 70 that is
world-class for a lab test this is how
passionately people feel about our
service
LabCorp and quest NPS is negative so I
share this because but to be clear it's
not because they're not providing value
it's the question of who is the value
for who is the value for and so as the
value will shift more towards the
patient and the consumer I do think
you'll start to see pressure across
across the Sahel --the care delivery
chain right is this is the moment for
the consumerization of health care we've
heard that phrase forever we've heard
the phrase personalized health we've
heard the phrase digital health all of
this is different ways of caring about
the patient and I think you'll finally
start to see that come to the head and
companies and large organizations have
to do something about it
do you see a world where that brick and
mortar kind of much more I'll call
bureaucrat has probably the wrong word
but they're just much more brick and
mortar in the kind of physical world
approach to lab testing there will
definitely be lab tests that always have
to be that way of course yeah
trend more towards this at-home
direct-to-consumer kind of what you're
doing or do you think there will be
coexistence of the two models right for
tests that can be at home and done
instruction consumer way I think until
we have innovation around blood
collection I think that the two models
will coexist there are many companies
working on this I really well exists to
hopefully partner with the companies
that are successful in doing that or
until we have a say innovation where
tests that are conducted usually via
blood can now be done via saliva or
urine or some other method so I think
that is really the next frontier is how
can we innovate around blood collection
such that it can it can really happen
and much more mass adoption and shift
away from these brick and mortar needs
which are expensive infrastructure and
yes they will have to exist for tested
naturally have to be done that way but
there's a quite a large number of common
tests that don't have to be done in a
brick-and-mortar setting and so I think
that innovation will be the next step
our goal is to be agnostic and say hey
when there is a great innovation that is
fda-approved
we want to be providing that experience
to our consumers and it puts us in a
really good position to capitalize on
that once it's available for people